Mình chỉ đã mời, Israel và Phong Chào Hamas đã chính đưa đảnh được thật thận đương bắn,
sau các cuộc đam phản giảm tiết tại Akeb.
Hamas chấp hận cho chả habi con tin còn sống để đổi lấy khoảng 20 tuần nhân,
8.4 trong đó của hai chim nâm mình người đang thu an Trung thân.
Chúc khi đó sẽ đảnh đau của thật thận, lượng phòng vệ Israel i đẹp.
Chấp hận, kiểm soát, nâng bất phần chăm diễn tích lãnh thổ xải khách ra.
Sĩ tính này được cho là nhỏ hơn 4 phần chăm, sau 1 sáng dưới đụng nèo trong đường phang
của bản kế hoạch bán đầu, dầu tổng thống Mỹ đường nân trăm được ra.
Cũng bị đỏ Israel cũng sẽ chức phần dút quân khỏi thành phố khách ra.
Cách nhà phân thích cho rằng để là cái khoảng của sức Akeb của tế ngày,
khẳng ra tăng, đã bị là tư phía Washington và đô 2.
Dù chứ thế xem là hoa bình bình vấn, nhưng thật tổn quan trọng này,
cũng đặt ra nên mong cho các cuộc đam phản sâu hơn kế tiết.
Và khoảng trọng nát là thắp lên y vọng trònh chữu dân sải khách ra,
những người đã sống quá lâu cho bắn tối của chính trang.
Còn chức kì đó tệ thành phố Khăn Tunis,
hàng chục trẻ em mô cô đã thăm ra của tổn thành tự nhiệm hai năm của sức độ.
Măng theo anh chá mẹ và biểu gử, kêu gọi hoa bình, dưới khởi hiệu,
chúng tôi không phải là những con số.
Nhưng đó chẻ này, năm chúc số khoảng nâng mình nhìn trẻ mất trẻ hoặc mẹ,
cây từ thống mời nâng anh in không tra liên bà,
chúng của cuộc khoảng nhìn đạo gại dài khách ra.